vocês acham que a gente boa tarde né
realmente nós temos de ter mobilidade é
também conhecido com tarifa zero e é um
movimento que surgiu aí a partida de
junho do ano passado as movimentações de
rua é todo mundo acompanhou e e embora
tenha nascido da rua ea gente tenha
realmente é essa como principal arma de
depressão de luta é um movimento também
estabelece diálogos com a sociedade é
mesmo antes de junho
mas aqui em bh especificamente partir de
junho
a gente tenta mostrar como tarifa zero
através de um gesto simples né
aparentemente simples como remover a
catraca de um ônibus na verdade está
contribuindo para tornar nossa sociedade
muito mais eficiente é muito mais justa
muito mais rica também muito mais
democrática muito mais acessível e
também mais saudável
mas antes de entrar especificamente o
projeto tarifa zero
a gente queria começar com alguns
projetos semelhantes estão sendo
propostas no legislativo
o primeiro deles está a discussão já num
comissão de energia do senado
apresentado com o senador de goiás
ele trata da iluminação urbana a idéia é
tornar a iluminação urbana mais
eficiente também mais justa que a pessoa
pague a medida é lavar utilizando né
então qualquer projeto qualquer proposta
senador a partir de agora os postes lu
de luz na cidade eles vão ter um
mecanismo é um time que você vai ter um
possibilidade de colocar moedas ou
cartões magnéticos vai ligar a luz só na
hora que realmente precisar o time vai
funcionar e por alguns minutos até você
pelo menos chegar até o próximo poste
a proposta do senador contempla questões
muito importante aqui no brasil ele já
está aprendendo que está sendo chamado
de bolsa após que é um cartão magnético
com a pessoas de baixa renda terem
direito a duas horas completamente
gratuita iluminação por mês
na mesma linha tem uma proposta lá em
cubatão de vereador também pra tornar
coleta de lixo mais 15 a partir de agora
o caminho onde de lixo vai parar na sua
casa tocar campainhas e vai descer pesar
seu lixo e vai pagar exatamente pelo
lixo que você produziu naquele dia uma
outra forma de também tornar mais justa
é a cobrança e um terceiro e último está
que também segue na mesma linha é de
estado do rio de janeiro que é pra
também aumentar o financiamento das
escolas ele argumenta que nem todo mundo
que parece que estuda em uma escola
pública é carente então que não se cobre
também pelas aulas nem aí uma tabela
diferenciada por cada disciplina os
alunos vão levar lá o dinheiro deles
pagar e passar pela catraca
bom gente é na verdade são brincadeiras
nem ninguém está levando a sério mesmo
mas elas eram a gente a pensar é o
primeiro mito que a gente busca
desconstruir tem esses disse não faz
todo o sentido que tem antes de onde
realmente a pessoa que paga e paga na
hora que tiver andando é hoje a gente
olha com um absurdo para aquelas coisas
que viu antes mas nem sempre foi assim
então é uma construção social que a
gente faz para tentar ver como é que a
gente pode fazer mais nacionalmente para
usar os nossos recursos e em coisas que
são importantes para o funcionamento da
sociedade inteira
no caso de transporte que o da cidade
inteira é então é essa lógica aqui que a
gente estava mostrando antes a lógica da
contrapartida imediata você paga
exatamente aquilo que você usa um
momento que você usa
ela não faz sentido quando a gente trata
de coisas como essa que a gente mostrou
antes que a gente reconhece como
direitos sociais são coisas fundamentais
pra gente pra nossa sociedade funcionar
e é irracional que seja cobrado a cada
momento que você usa quando você torna
um direito social
como quem quer fazer com o transporte
público é tudo fica mais fácil de ser
administrado
além de você ter despesas altíssimas
hoje só poder gerenciar é a cobrança das
passagens dos ônibus
você tem várias coisas que têm que levar
em consideração o que que a tarifa acaba
causando hoje na sociedade para a causa
um bloqueio à priori de muita coisa que
pode acontecer é é a mesma forma que o
que o fim das tarifas vai garantir o
acesso a diversos direitos como educação
e saúde
o fim da tarifa também garante a
movimentação da economia da cidade
hoje quando a pessoa uma família de
quatro pessoas que têm que pensar em
oito passagens
ela não sai de casa ela deixe de acessar
o comércio no centro restaurante o
cinema opções de lazer gratuitas que ela
que a prefeitura oferece tudo isso por
conta da da passagem então essa passagem
está transformando um bloqueio que está
estagnado toda a economia da cidade e
agora sim as irracionalidades que o
sistema produz pra gente
além do ano passado quando a gente
estava ocupa na câmara aqui em belo
horizonte
o prefeito nos chamou para conversar e
ele apresentou uma contra-proposta
tarifa zero que seria é enfrentar a
tarifa apenas de pessoas de baixa renda
e aparentemente parece justo né mas
ainda assim ela guarda sérios problemas
ela também o fato de você querer
diferenciar as pessoas que pagam pagam
um ônibus você acaba tendo que manter a
mesma estrutura de hoje e que isso gera
um dos exemplos são as filas nos pontos
é é não não é por acaso quando você vê o
ônibus parado cinco minutos ali no
centro e pelas 6 horas da tarde
você tem que esperar todo mundo tá do
lado de fora entrar passar pela catraca
espremê-la no fundo até até onde pode
sair em cinco minutos pode parecer pouco
mas se você multiplicar se por todos os
pontos vai passar e falar isso o
trabalhador que está rezando chegar em
casa oito horas da noite saber que isso
não é desprezível
o segundo ponto muito importante também
que a lógica da tarifa é ataca
diretamente a qualidade do sistema
pra você ter o ônibus hoje que funciona
em bairros muito
mas para eles chegarem até até o centro
ele vai percorrer a distância muito
maior cobrando o mesmo valor da tarifa o
que que a pessoa que administrou em si
tem que pensar eu não posso ver com esse
ônus vazios não precisa ser muito grande
qualquer qualquer resposta então você
demora anos a passar pra que acumule
bastante gente no ponto e você consegue
encher onde completará a capacidade de
lhe trazer até o centro com o menor
prejuízo possível então essa lógica de
manter os ônibus sempre cheio
não é por acaso gente é o coração é a
essência do sistema de tarifas que a
gente tem hoje um ônibus cheio é
significa racionalmente para quem
administra aquele negócio a significa
exatamente que há negócio dele vai se
manter sentado à medida que você diminui
a lotação dos ônibus é o negócio parados
e sustentável e as pessoas num é enfim
um negócio vai render ea última coisa
que a gente entende por exemplo que
quando os homens estão sempre cheios a
pessoa tende a realmente ficar sonhando
né em comprar o carro dela
você pega um ônibus lá lotado com 100
pessoas aquelas 100 pessoas as duas
horas que elas estão viajando até chegar
ao seu destino exatamente fazemos planos
pra financiar o carro dela sair daquela
condição né
e é esse problema os se todas as pessoas
comprarem carro a gente já sabe qual a
consequência disso por trans
um outro mito também que a gente tem
tentado desconstruir é quando a gente
ouve 17 anos mas já já existe
vale-transporte né assim que é mais que
a gente pode fazer é em primeiro lugar
assim vale transporte seja está falando
que existe para o transporte
a gente está falando de de quem tem
carteira assinada primeiramente quem tem
emprego formal tem carteira assinada a
gente até excluindo um monte de gente
sair dessa lista néel quem trabalho por
conta própria ou quem está mais informal
no mercado de trabalho
uma outra questão que normalmente vai
transporte é visto como um benefício
para empregado então com sevilla anúncio
procurando algum tipo de de empregado
salário tal benefício vale transporte
siim concebível nesse o próprio
empregador ele precisa de seu
deslocamento para o local de trabalho
não pode ser nunca um benefício de
empregado nem e isso efetivamente é
funciona como uma discriminação porque
quem mora mais longe sempre preterido
por quem mora mais perto porque tem que
gastar menos para se deslocar nem fora
que o essencial é que a gente tem que
mudar essa forma essa lógica de pensar
que a nossa mobilidade é só de casa para
o trabalho e do trabalho para casa a
gente tem que se deslocar só pra vender
nossa força de trabalho nem a isso
restringe seu limite e se empobrecem a
vida na cidade é tudo que a cidade tem
para oferecer para a gente nem e nem
sente teve uma experiência muito
interessante que o coletivo é que eu
quero fazer é é proporcionar neste
carnaval né que foi abuso na tarifa zero
que rodou um ônibus gratuito e durante
quatro dias do carnaval é é de fazer
nesse deslocamento entre os blocos de
carnaval foi super divertido nas pessoas
é s e se essa questão de se deslocar
para divertimento para o lazer e isso é
muito importante mas não só isso
proporciona também outra relação com a
cidade de repente alguém que que não
pense na uma volta pela cidade de de
ônibus ou porque ou porque têm que pagar
2 65 neckel porque eu vou pagar 2 65
para dar uma volta pela cidade de
repente isso têm outra relação a gente
pode passear a pé a gente pode passear
de bicicleta mas ele porque não a gente
pode passear de ônibus pela cidade desde
que seja gratuito né
então é bem interessante mãe é
proporcionar outro tipo de relação
também aí todo mundo acha bacana até
aqui mas perguntar mas eu não uso
transporte o que eu tenho a ver com essa
história né tem tudo a ver com essa
história primeiro a gente pensa que todo
dia no amazonas às 7 horas da manhã para
o trabalho a gente fica puto com aquele
tanto de ônibus e tatá é travando o
trânsito a gente tem que pensar que que
aquelas pessoas todos que estão
esmagadíssimas ele no ônibus elas
tivessem nos seus cargos nem como classe
falou cielo já tivessem conseguido
comprar o seu próprio carro tivesse ele
disputando o espaço urbano com você
a ace na mobilidade estava toda travada
que é na verdade o que já tem acontecido
a gente já tem visto isso e um quadro
muito interessante que ilustra isso é
foi produzido pela folha de são paulo e
fala sobre o espaço urbano ocupado uma
vida capital paulista
então assim é muito gritante a
discrepância esses azulzinhos é que são
os carros e eles ocupam 78% do espaço
urbano enquanto os ônibus
os coletivos que são os vermelhinhos
ocupam seis por cento do espaço urbano
então você vê esse outro lado aqui que
os carros que transportam 109 erro duas
pessoas e os ônibus 214 mil e 59
veja bem os carros só conseguem
transportar metade do que os ônibus
transportam porque eles ocupam 78% do
espaço é migrar as políticas que estão
sendo adotadas de emigrar
então sempre assim não convida um pra
para o transporte para o transporte
coletivo
aí sempre que tem oportunidade migra-se
próprio transporte individual outro
motivo isso significa além de
congestionamento significa onerar mais o
o transporte coletivo para quem depende
dele porque aí é o mesmo é o mesmo custo
sendo rateado por menos pessoas nem e
então a link é é um uma um exemplo de
estar e fazer tallin capital da estônia
é uma cidade 420 mil habitantes a gente
tem experiência que implantar e fazer em
2013 e logo nos três primeiros meses já
teve uma queda de 15% no número de
veículos e é conseqüentemente no
congestionamento é claro que a gente
sabe que a supressão do da cobrança
imediata ela não ela não funciona ela
ver sozinha tem que ter participação
popular na gestão do sistema então é
isso é decidido sobre linhas decidindo
sobre itinerários sobre quadro de
horários sobre física é fiscalizar o
sistema então assim é claro que é um
conjunto de ações mas a gente tem que
começar a pensar que a gente quer outro
tipo de sistema de transporte
outra coisa que a gente ganha em saúde
isso aqui é uma é uma foto de página da
torre eiffel
o governo de paris há pouco mais de um
mês adotou uma medida porque os níveis
de poluição atmosférica estavam maiores
do que os permitidos pela organização
mundial de saúde e uma e uma medida
emergencial foi adotada foi implementada
de fazer durante alguns dias pra que
obviamente fosse reduzido mas que as
pessoas começassem a ter essa cultura de
preferir o transporte coletivo ao invés
de transporte individual automotivo
fora que a gente ganha também segurança
a gente que a gente anda pelas ruas hoje
em dia a gente vê assim é só carro e
mais gente circulando na rua é mais
segurança coletiva também aí vem a
pergunta que todo mundo quer escutar nem
quem vai pagar pelo transporte coletivo
nem tão assim tem um tem um gráfico
muito interessante que mostra várias
capitais é várias várias cidades da
europa e como que é o financiamento do
transporte público aqui a gente tem que
é maior a maior parte da receita do
transporte não é a dívida
tarifa como acontece aqui em belo
horizonte isso é uma das formas
a gente está falando a verdade mudança
de de prioridades no orçamento público
tá é quando a bhtrans por exemplo
presidente da bhtrans fala que é que a
meta de belo horizonte é que 70% das
pessoas utilizem o transporte público
como em barcelona que foi o que ele
citou ele esqueceu disse tá que 50% da
receita do transporte é subsidiada e
aqui não acontece isso tá e então assim
o coletivo teve uma experiência quando
foi pro propor uma emenda o ppa g que
verificassem que gastos com a a
prefeitura gasta por exemplo mais de 1
bilhão de reais com o projeto corta
caminho que são projetos de construção
dia alargamento de manutenção de vias
então a gente tem todo um orçamento que
está muito mais direcionado para o
transporte individual automotivo do que
para o transporte coletivo
a gente tem esse nível municipal
estadual e federal a gente tem exemplos
onde ipi para a compra de carro
a gente tem um monte de coisa que que
incentiva muito mais o transporte
individual automotivo
nessa mesma linha vem essa pergunta mas
existe almoço grátis se a gente pensar
assim o almoço grátis que hoje existe é
para a indústria automobilística que
ganha grande e grandes incentivos do
governo é para a compra de carro que tem
redução de ipi
entre os motoristas de carro também que
por exemplo usufruindo tráfego né de
construção de viaduto de rodovia de
alargamento
mas no banco eles não contribuem pra
isso então a gente tem que começar a
pensar nessa lógica é um exemplo disso é
esse viaduto na natureza cristina é foi
construído foi a 140 milhões do do
orçamento público e ainda ganhou como
viaduto mais feio tá lá no guiness e foi
gastar 140 milhões do orçamento público
e nos dava da bhtrans tomazina que agora
está tudo tranqüilo que quem faz o
trajeto da
a contagem vai gastar uma hora tá de boa
que vai gastar 56 minutos então tá tudo
bem
a sony acaba não só dar um recado final
só pra falar mesmo que fizeram nada mais
é do que rever a forma com que a gente
já gasta o nosso dinheiro com transporte
ninguém acha que dá nada de graça na rua
mas é mais do que isso é ver os gastos
que a gente já tem hoje como é que se
pode fazer para melhorar
obrigado obrigado